some people are finding trauma and
racism and everything these days
including camping NBC News facing
criticism for a report about how black
people need their own safe spaces to
enjoy the great outdoors in the article
titled meet the black outdoorsy groups
reclaiming the joys of nature one
outdoor Enthusiast saying quote there
were a lot of black people looking for
safe spaces to go camping and just
experience the outdoors people would go
to campgrounds and there would be Trump
flags flying everywhere critics slamming
the piece for suggesting segregation in
nature is camping racist Jesse
only when Greg goes camping that is true
but think about how racist this would be
if it would be the other way around yeah
what if what if some white guy said you
know what went into the city over the
weekend took the family all these black
people there I didn't feel safe you know
they had all these Obama t-shirts on
that person would be canceled you can't
say that you can't say that about
anybody black or white anything and I
encourage all Races to go camping as
everybody knows I am the resident camper
at Fox news I've spent more time in the
wilderness than anybody at this company
yes I have I know you have yes I have
yes I won't do it I haven't done it a
long time
and I'm never going camping again not
because there's other people with
different races because I'm spoiled now
okay so what exactly is going on here
Jessica what do you believe is happening
inside these campgrounds
well I think that this is one of those
click bait articles I don't think that
this is
a real thing that's happening pretend
like it's real for the segment why well
I have more to say about it I mean the
article references that there used to be
whites only signs during Jim Crow but
those signs obviously no longer exist
and as a white person I don't Camp
um but I I know that the black
experience in America is different than
the white experience you just look at
how many times black person has pulled
over while they're driving versus a
white person who's pulled over when
they're driving especially when they're
camping
well campers also Zoom
um so I just when was the last time you
were at a campground judge oh
and did you see that spaces may be
required when I was when I was a kid we
went camping once in a while with my
uncle he was really into it but you know
this sounds like one of those fake
grievances you're going camping it's a
big it's a big country move your Camp
somewhere else if you don't like to be
sometimes you don't like people because
you don't like their music you don't
like the way they look you don't like
because they drink too much you know
this is now they may have a flag you
don't like to fly well go somewhere else
stop it it's like a bunch of teenage
girls right you know they're they've got
like these the the they're in a click
and they wanna they wanna be drama
queens and if someone in the other
Clique like raises an eyebrow oh there's
more drama this is I don't buy it I
don't know Greg do you ever feel like
you may need a safe space I just find it
hilarious that they consider the
Wilderness a safe space
I mean we work at a news station like
half the deaths are like turned up in
the bottom of a ravine half eaten by
Wolves it's like so and so went missing
we still haven't found him oh no the
helicopter has spotted a cadaver it's
not white people to worry about its
Bears it's Bears I have bears and it's
it it's funny too because like I think
part of the article if I read it
correctly was talking about leaving the
city after certain political things like
January 6 and all that stuff and I'm
thinking most people are leaving the
city because of the crime they're not
leaving it because of Republicans and
they're not leaving the woods because of
Republicans it's funny I mean it's like
you notice that with every facet uh in
this race-based identity cult the
solution is always going to be
segregation that's the solution who
thought that the that the left would
find common ground with the KKK and it's
a campground
I'm just noting my objection no no I
believe no but this is summer I would
say this is summer news but this came
out maybe a month ago technically this
is spring news
21st Lilly Mayer retired school teacher
says this is a race baiting asinine idea
that black people would need safe places
to enjoy the outdoors they're not that
fragile we should have bussing to
campgrounds
that's what Joe Biden was for exactly
right um coming up wait till you hear
what we have Hulk Hogan making a huge
life announcement but some say he did it
at the worst possible place I went on
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now